[Music]
in abandon ship news submitted by Nike
or ID I did this depends
I like a boss now I like a boss like a
boss
I like a boss depending I like good Nike
I like boss to book a couple sold
everything they own to go on a sailing
adventure but the boat sank just two
days later that was a swing and a Miss
yeah did they over pack and that's what
happened or just about a shitty but has
it like Dettol is it like the Ilia story
where they over pack the plane or
whatever is that what happened yeah yeah
dog
dad over pack the planes too much dog
luggage I thought the plane just sucked
well no no they overweight it mm-hmm
she wanted to bring a lot of clothes or
something she would bring all her
clothes no I think it was like equipment
okay but I like blaming the one that
always don't talk about my allele like
that all right I'm sorry move on did you
pack Sephora the whole store the two
tons of foundation please put it away
yes so this couple they sold everything
they owned or in whatever they did keep
like sentimental value which means
possession or in that boat and they are
all gone I don't know why it's so sad
it's so funny at the same time
well it's cuz it's like you bet it
already to you laughs where you built it
up you're like we're going to Vegas
it's we're gonna make a million dollars
we're gonna bet on red then we're gonna
take it where we start this business and
then it's like you put it on red and
they're like sorry you watch the work
you come out just clear at least it
reminds me of this video that I saw I
was like this girl she's going bungee
jumping right and you could tell she's
been hyped to do this her whole life and
there's just one ghetto friend recording
this show you go don't do that [ __ ]
that's just dangerous I'm telling you
man I don't know why you wanted she
jumps right she goes if they did better
the late flight as you
Splatt right into like some water right
and it was like shallow water too and
then she's all [ __ ] up you just hear
her friend go I told you [ __ ]
friends like eating a [ __ ] corndog
like I told you man this hilarious [ __ ]
did this [ __ ]
oh yeah she got right back up but that
was [ __ ] hilarious so the friend was
filming it yeah
oh my god do you hear that behind the
KU's here talking throughout the whole
camera they just hilarious that's so
funny it's the reason why it's funny
it's I'm their friend my inner friend is
going why would you sell everything and
Bank everything on just one trip you
[ __ ] idiot and then it says the boat
sink I'm like I told you [ __ ]
nothing is funnier than watching a boat
sink though right the Titanic must have
been a real laugh riot
comedy I will say when that person who
died in the theater had the ship and
they hit the propeller and they spun it
was hilarious
I thought the irony was great I heard of
the Lusitania went down there the pilots
were laughing so hard they almost crash
depending on [ __ ] thing yeah because
a plane crash is so horrific it's so sad
it's like ah you see it Wow and it's
like an explosion right but a boat
sinking it's like it is going down flow
the same sound like a little kid makes
when they're making a fish sound yeah
yeah so this couple Mickey and tenner on
Mickey's 24 tenors 26 and they have
their hug in the sunlight there hey I'm
home I got a red head like a red
forehead I find this to be a very
insensitive picture that she's making
fun of Asian people I was gonna say I
wasn't brave I wish to trade on winning
because now that I saw
I'm actually because you actually look
like my mom so take that off right now
yes sir they bought this boat in Alabama
all that looks cool adobo it's a 1969
boat for $5,000 that's the deal
and they spent another five thousand
fixing it up of some $5,000 boat yeah so
they didn't have any sailing experience
but that's always good
oh that's where you [ __ ] should've took
some lessons or something so Dan
Tanner's dad helped them huh I'll buy a
newer boat if you don't know anything
about sailing yeah you buy almost 50
year old boat dude what do you think is
gonna happen look if I don't know how to
ride a motorcycle I'm not gonna buy a
1950s motorcycle I'm gonna probably buy
something with cruise control and [ __ ]
all kinds of sensors and [ __ ] but I was
what they could afford that's what they
could afford because they spent a whole
year saving up that's how it's done it's
a pretty good idea McDonald's with some
dreams of $2,000 tip tip why are we
doing this article this is stupid I got
the rest of the damn story their dad
helped them out with the with the
sailboat yeah so Tanner's dad helped
them sail from Alabama to Florida okay
they lived in Colorado then they moved
to Florida prepare that's a long ways
yeah so then please tell me they didn't
even make it out of the dock they did
they did how long how far did they make
it like two days oh well I just scary
there on the ocean because I pictured
them like out of the dock as thinking I
was gonna travel somewhere I would just
only travel along the coast like still
see land oh yeah especially it was my
first time I'm [ __ ] around
if you can't navigate hell it's like the
kid and we're learning how to swim is
always on the wall of the pool you don't
want to be that [ __ ] stupid ass kid
that's not a swim and it's also going
like this and then I'll be scraping the
sad and [ __ ] dude if I told Nicky I feel
like yeah but if I told Nikki all my
Haven what do you think about we buy a
book she's like oh my god what what did
you do yeah you wanna mean like let's go
out on the sea or whatever she's like
are you just giving up on everything
you're giving up on your dreams
everything you think I don't know
know how I could get his mind for them
selling is a dream for them I want to be
on a boat yeah so then uh they ended up
leaving right from the from the original
location and then finally two days later
they were going through this pass and
they said but em they're going through
this certain pass it was really night
time was really dark Nicky was using her
flashlight for Tanner to steer the boat
and like try to dock but then they
somehow hit something under the town low
tide
well it seems after the hurricane after
Emma it must have like shifted things
around and so the tunnel way has like
don't blame it on her Moe [ __ ] up
because they're saying that the buoys
are whatever they're using to siddhappa
it's not where it was supposed to be a
move hurricane movie that make sense
after a hurricane yeah it was on top of
a restaurant yeah so then they ended up
hitting something and it hit it so hard
that Nikki almost flew off so then
immediately they went under
it should've drove slower and then they
thought they saw that other stuff
started just the water started coming up
and all their stuff fell out because
because that hit was so hard even though
they had things tied down was just
everything was like flowing everywhere
oh we had enough time to take a picture
do a selfie do a face tell the world hey
we're sinking right now take it again
with the flash on yesterday I'm like
yeah and so they were only able to grab
a couple a couple things which was like
their security cards some cash oh [ __ ]
that's it that's their whole garage
looks like everything so then this is
what the boat looks like now they lived
right there fine okay they're fine and
the dog was fine too and oh yeah yeah
but Nikki was just saying that she was
like trying to dial for like the the
seto then she was just shaking so my
judge is there oh my gosh
yes on a sinking boat not only that but
it's like your entire life and I would
never put my entire life in a boat I put
it in a storage space yeah yeah how
would you put what did you bring with
you that you also I don't know why they
brought their entire life on the boat
I would leave all that [ __ ] in a storage
space and bring only bow items
what are they real oh they're living in
that like their their dream is to just
sail and just live on the boat so that's
why all of their belongings are on that
that's done that for like 40 years or
something it's crazy they live around
the world yeah and so they're saying now
that lifeguards or the Coast Guard told
them that they need to remove their boat
from the water and that's gonna cost
about $10,000 they only have about $90
to their name that's up this is why you
don't buy a [ __ ] boat everyone knows
this right like anyone whoever gets
money knows not to buy a boat because it
cost so much [ __ ] money I have no
idea oh there was more money to keep a
boat that is to buy it I want a boat
though but you can't dude you're gonna
be poor dude I want a horse to live in
Amsterdam you can have a boat there I'm
not saying her dreams or their dreams
are dumb and I'm not saying that if you
have a dream of sailing the world is
dumb the way they went about it with no
sailing experience and putting all their
items in that boat that's the dumb way
they go about like you saw it was
possible those baby steps to doing what
you yeah leading up to them leaving yeah
they did work at a place where they like
sell and rent boats and so they were
able to learn about them all Oh Joe's
Crab Shack yeah I'm glad that they got
experi and I'm glad they mastered the
canoe but interest and a Joe's Crab
Shack for ten years I know exactly what
I'm doing I worked at the Red Lobster I
know I think it's dope I think it was a
brave bold move and I'm like good for
you guys it's a fortunate that it turned
out to be this way lesson learn a twenty
thousand dollar lesson learned
yeah and also all the sentimental items
law lesson there it's all gone now so
and you will never ever ever see it
again we're gonna buy a really dope boat
next or they're just gonna get it the
ninety dollars in the name well the cool
thing is they're still young and they
can do it again and try it again
are they gonna turn if they really want
to be pirates I think they could do it
yeah I don't they want to be a pirate
you know after your divorce you can find
some other love - it's good I think the
next best dream is to get a bunch of
more stuff again I accumulated for five
to ten years and then I decide to put
all that stuff in a plane that they've
never flown before and try to fly that
around the world and see what happens
buy a 1950s plane but they're gonna live
in a plane yeah live in the plane by
playing for $5,000 to try to fly around
cool I wanna like live in a world war
two plane the one with a glass
underneath what is what does his dad do
does he also work at Joe's Crab Shack I
would live on a boat no joke if I could
stay on the dock the whole time yes see
ya and then you just you save all kind
of money because they're on rent right
they wanted to travel so that's why you
want to travel the world I see have you
seen those billionaire yachts though
they want to take that little boat raizy
yeah so they are saying that their dream
is not dead that they are gonna good for
them they're they started a GoFundMe
shot of course they did may have
surpassed their goal oh and your face
David there's fourteen thousand now you
know why people love seeing other people
there's achieved their dreams could they
live through them because they're like I
hate my life but I'm too scared
so let me just pay for these couple to
do it okay they just want to see them
sink another boat or a plane that's even
better
yes what we should have done is that I
will give you money for your GoFundMe
and I'll fund the whole thing through
but now you need to go on a 1920s plane
that's right right have your dad fix it
put off your other belongings if I want
to see them [ __ ] spin the propeller
I'll pay for this if you guys do it on
an older boat yep
much older I want to see them do it in
like an old bus a very old one but then
the designs being so safe it's very safe
yeah they liked to gamble they need like
a submarine or something yeah oh yeah
a really old summer all bow on an old
submarine you know the cartel was doing
that actually they were buying old
Russian submarines and they were like
smuggling cocaine like that
that's a pretty dope idea
[Music]
[Music]